[Music]
in the world of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Captain America has always been
a key and above all popular character
but times change and a lot has happened
since Steve Rogers retirement at the end
of Avengers end game in the new
installment of the Captain America
franchise called Brave New World we see
a new hero behind the vibranium shield
with Sam Wilson after inheriting the
famous signature shield from the old
Captain America in the Disney plus
series The Falcon and the Winter Soldier
he is now pursuing his own path which is
surely not an easy one in our video you
can now learn all the latest information
about the plot cast and production of
Captain America 4 so that you're up to
date on the MCU project
let's turn our attention to the
potential plot in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Sam Wilson struggled with
the decision of whether he should accept
the shield and become the new Captain
America over the course of the series
Sam chooses to embrace his Destiny and
fulfill Steve Rogers wish Sam reached
this decision in the final episode of
the Falcon in the Winter Soldier which
came out on Disney Plus in April 2021 on
the same day The Hollywood Reporter
revealed that a fourth Captain America
movie was in the works although we don't
have many specific details about the
storyline of Brave New World yet there
are some Clues as to how the story will
unfold for example in an interview with
Screen Rant director Julius Ona talked
about how the movie will be a paranoid
Thriller which is consistent with the
previous Captain America movies
especially the Winter Soldier Ona also
disclosed that Sam will face the leader
in the film who act as the main
antagonist for those who don't remember
Tim Blake Nelson's character Samuel
Stearns has only made one previous
appearance in the MCU and that was in
2008's The Incredible Hulk where he
played a scientist working on an
antidote for Bruce Banner's anger
problem however working with Bruce's
blood samples resulted in far-reaching
problems Emile Blonsky became
Abomination and Stearns became the
leader in the comics he's a mastermind
with an oversized head and one of the
Hulk's many adversaries it will be
interesting to see how his intelligence
comes across as a main weapon against
Sam as the new cap there's also Harrison
Ford's character of Thaddeus Ross who
has risen through the ranks from General
to the new U.S president after the
events of Avengers Civil War Ross had
Sam Wilson in prison for violating the
sokovia court so it's no secret and it
was also confirmed by producer Nate
Moore that Wilson and the new U.S
president are going to clash cap will
probably have to deal with more than
just one antagonist and prove that he is
worthy of the role of Captain America in
regards to Captain America himself
director Julius Ona spoke to IGN about
what awaits Sam as the new bearer of The
Shield according to Ona Sam will have to
face the consequences of his decision to
accept the shield and fight not only
super villains but also of the
government the military and the public
on a statements matched Sam's
experiences in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier in which he was exposed to
America's dubious history and the
expectations of a black Captain America
equally interesting is the recent change
in the movie's title while the original
title New World Order is often used in
connection with conspiracy theories
Brave New World suggests a new beginning
of sorts and is also the title of the
dystopian novel of the same name by
Aldous Huxley in the context of
America's past the term is also often
used to describe a time of renewal and
change usually following a significant
event or major change this could refer
to Sam's role as the new Captain America
and how he continues the legacy of Steve
Rogers in a world that has undergone
drastic change
the well-known cast of Captain America 4
already gives us an idea of what to
expect various actors from the existing
MCU are playing in the movie however a
number of familiar names are also
missing as they no longer seem to play a
role in the story
first and foremost among the cast is of
course Chris Evans successor Anthony
Mackey who reprises the role of Sam
Wilson now known as the new Captain
America at the time of the movies
Premiere more than 10 years will have
passed since Falcon joins his friend
Steve Rogers to defeat Hydra in the last
episode of Falcon and the Winter Soldier
we already got a glimpse of his costume
unlike Steve he also has his flight suit
at his disposal of course
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross will no longer
be played by the late William Hurt but
by Harrison Ford the return of the
character makes many people prick up
their ears since Ross eventually becomes
the legendary Red Hulk in the comics in
an interview Ford was promptly asked
about it the experienced star simply
replied in his usual Curt manner what's
a red Hulk of course it would be the
first time MCU actors have deliberately
pretended to be clueless so as not to
give anything away likewise returning is
Ross's daughter Betty Ross who will once
again be portrayed by Liv Tyler as in
the 2008 Hulk film whether she will play
a significant role in this movie is not
yet known however
the villain Dr Samuel Stearns AKA The
Leader is played by Tim Blake Nelson as
was the case in The Incredible Hulk at
the end of the Hulk movie he himself
came into contact with Banner's blood
and his head began to swell in addition
to telepathic abilities in the comics
leader also has robots that he built
himself and that fight on his side we're
eager to find out what he has to do with
the crime organization New World Order
from the comics which will certainly be
playing a big role after all Captain
America 4 even included the name in its
title until it was renamed
Shira Haas takes on the role of the
Israeli superheroine Sabra whose real
name is Ruth bat saraf the actress has
appeared in the miniseries unorthodox
for example the introduction of Sabra
into the MCU caught the attention of
many comic book readers because at least
in the comics she is not only an agent
but also a mutant with the Cameo
appearance of Charles Xavier and Doctor
Strange 2 Multiverse of Madness the
mentions of mutations in Ms Marvel and
Hugh Jackman's future appearance as
Wolverine in Deadpool 3. this reinforces
the signs for further Integrations of
the X-Men into the MCU
another big name in the cast of Captain
America Brave New World is Elita battle
Angel leading actress Rosa Salazar it is
not known which character she will play
however many speculate that she will
take on the role of the villainous
Diamondback a part of the evil
organization serpent Society there are
also rumors that WWE star Seth Rollins
will also portray a member of the crime
group Carl lumbley otherwise known as
Isaiah Bradley will also be back in
action the Aged super soldier will
probably no longer take an active part
in battle but he will certainly be on
hand offer advice and support to the
young cap Danny Ramirez is also back in
the cast Ramirez embodies the CIA agent
Joaquin Torres who drew Sam's attention
to the threat posed by the flag Smashers
in the series and now joins as falcon
fans of Falcon in the Winter Soldier
have to be aware that Sebastian Stan as
Bucky Barnes will not be appearing in
Brave New World at least that's the
official situation of course there are
numerous rumors about a surprise
appearance while Sam will otherwise have
to cope with the New World Order on his
own fans can at least look forward to
Bucky's role in the Marvel movie
Thunderbolts which will hit theaters a
few months later on December 20th 2024.
unlike the previous Captain America
movies which were directed by the Russo
Brothers the new movie will be directed
by Julius Ona he previously made a name
for himself with the Cloverfield Paradox
and with only three movies to date has
rather little experience in the business
the script is written by Malcolm
Spellman and dalen Musson who are both
involved in the series The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier and are therefore
very well acquainted with the story at
the moment filming is in its final
stages after Disney recently pushed back
all possible MCU projects the current
theatrical release of Captain America
Brave New World is scheduled for July 26
2024.
we hope you enjoyed our new original
what are your expectations for Captain
America Brave New World and do you think
Sam Wilson can follow in Steve Rogers
footsteps let us know in the comments
down below
foreign
[Music]